-It is time to play a game of deception called
"True Confessions."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My first opponent tonight is an award-winning actress
who stars in the new Netflix series
"Inventing Anna."
Please welcome Laverne Cox!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You floated in. You floated --
Welcome. You kind of floated in.
Laverne and I will be facing off
against a multi-talented actor and director.
His new series, "Severance,"
can be seen every Friday on Apple TV Plus.
Please welcome Ben Stiller!
Wow! That's --Whoa!
Equally -- Equally, beautifully.
What an entrance. Equally beautiful.
Good to see you, pal. -Nice to see you.
-Guys, this is how each of this works.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes containing confessions.
One is true. The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession, the other two players
get to interrogate you,
then they have to come up to a unanimous decision.
Is it a truth? Or is it a lie?
Laverne, you're going to go first.
Which envelope should she open?
-I'm holding up... -What do you think, Ben?
-...two envelopes.
-Two. -Right. Okay.
-Two. Right? -Good.
-We didn't do this. -So that wasn't prearranged.
-No, that wasn't --
-See? Is this how it is at the restaurant when you're ordering?
-Oh, my God.
-[ Clears throat ]
-When I got "Orange is the New Black,"
I celebrated with a nice dinner.
But then my card was declined, which is ironic
because my character was in jail for credit-card fraud.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. -That's irony, right?
-Now, what year was this?
"Orange is the New Black" was what?
-So, we shot the first season in 2012,
so that was 10 years ago.
And the first season premiered in 2013.
But when I booked the show in 2012,
it was an intense year for me,
and I've actually talked about this before publicly.
It was the year I turned 40.
I was actually gonna stop acting
because I was in rent arrears in February of 2012.
-I feel like you're talking a lot.
-She's talking too much. Yeah. There's too much detail.
I asked one question, right?
-Do you want to ask me a question?
-Yeah. -Ask me a question.
-Why were you declined? Why was it declined?
-Why is anybody's credit card declined?
-That's true. I don't know --
I don't know exactly why -- -Didn't have any money.
-Didn't have any money.
-What year were credit cards invented?
[ Laughter ]
-See? He throws you off.
He throws you off with those questions.
-So, Mr. Stiller, I know I'm a woman
of a certain age, but I'm not that old.
-No, yeah. -Okay. I have a question.
Simple question. What was the restaurant?
-The restaurant is this restaurant called L'Express
here in New York City.
I ordered the grilled salmon that you put on a salad,
but without the salad because it was lighter and cheaper
than the salmon that you would get as an entrée,
and then that would have a lot of shredded Parmesan cheese
on the salmon -- -Doesn't sound like something
that no one with a credit card would order normally.
Just saying.
-Like the pièce de résistance, she orders their French fries,
'cause they're my favorite French fries in the city.
They're so delicious. Do you know --
You know the French fries at L'Express.
-The frites.
-They're really good French fries.
-French fries, yes. -Pommes frite.
-Pommes frite. I am saying absolutely that this is a lie.
-Lie. Total lie.
-Laverne Cox.
Is it the truth or is it a lie?
[ Drum roll ]
-It's a lie.
-Whoa! We did it! -Whoo!
♪♪
-Okay. It is my turn right now. Which envelope should I open?
One or two? -[ Audience shouting, "One" ]
-One. One.
-I was one of the voices on U2's hit song "Vertigo."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cox laughing ]
-What year was the song released?
-The song?
[ Laughter ]
It was released -- It's got to be 2005 or something.
-Right. That sounds like -- Right, yeah.
-This was -- Yeah. -How did it happen?
-[ Chuckles ] I was at a party with Bono.
-[ Laughter ] -That's believable.
-Michael Stipe was one of the people there.
We had a bunch of friends hanging out,
and he was talking about he was recording his new album.
I said, "Cool."
And he goes, "Let me play you a song,"
and he played me "Vertigo" on his phone.
[ Laughter ]
And so -- -I want to cross-check this
with the invention of the iPhone.
-Yeah. I don't know --
I don't know if it was an iPhone.
-There were no iPhones in 2004, obviously.
-Are you gonna play it on a BlackBerry?
-I think it was an mp3 player. Maybe not a phone.
It was something. -And now -- Okay.
I'm a little confused. Everything's changing now.
-So he goes, "But I want to add some part here
after 'Hello, hello.'
And he goes, "I want to say 'hello!'
Can we get all of you to scream "hello"?
We called his phone and left a message on his phone.
And I go, "Hola!"
[ Laughter ]
And what you hear on the record
is me on Bono's voicemail singing "Hola!"
[ Laughter ]
-I -- -Hola!
-Right.
-♪ Hello, hello! ♪
Hola!
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's true.
-I think it's true, as well.
[ Drum roll ]
-It is a lie. I was never in that song.
-Whoa.
♪♪
Wow. -Not bad.
Here we go right now. Ben, it is your -- Yeah.
I will say for, Ben Stiller, number one or two?
Alright. So we're going number two?
-Alright. Do number two. -He's a legend.
-Thank you.
[ Chuckles ] Um...
-He laughs as he looks at it.
-I almost made a movie with Mick Jagger.
-What movie did you almost make with Mick Jagger?
-This is similar to my story.
-Um, I almost made a movie with Mick Jagger
that was a concert film
that I was going to direct
and act in with myself and Brad Pitt.
Based on the story that these two super fans
were following the Rolling Stones all around,
and I was one and Brad Pitt was the other one and --
-[ Laughter ] -And we were --
-I've known you for a long time,
and I know that you love crazy stories.
-Wow. -No, no, no. Yeah. Right.
-You have some crazy stories.
Didn't you -- You once almost fought
Boom Boom Mancini in the ring.
-[ Laughs ] I did. I alm-- I was going to a boxing gym.
-Boom Boom Mancini, were they on the --
"Flintstones"? Boom Boom Mancini?
-No. The boxer. -It's a boxing champion.
-Famous boxer.
[ Laughter ]
You're thinking of Bamm-Bamm.
-That sounds like a lie. Oh, Bamm-Bamm.
-Yeah. Boom Boom. Bamm-Bamm. Wait. Sorry.
This has nothing to do with Boom Boom or Bamm-Bamm.
-So, this definitely happened.
We were going to do this film where we follow them around,
and Mick actually -- It was his idea,
and he wanted to do the film and --
-What did he say to you?
[as Jagger] "Let's go. I got to do a movie with you."
-Right. Yeah. But I've got convince --
I'll tell you what to say, you do the --
-[Normal voice] You tell me what to say. He says what?
-He said, "I think this is a great idea for a concert film."
-"I really think it's a great idea for a concert film."
-"But I've got to convince the rest of the band."
-"But! I gotta convince the rest of the band!"
-"'Cause Keith really isn't into it."
-♪ Keith isn't into it, Keith isn't into it ♪
♪ I can't convince him, man, 'cause Keith isn't into it ♪
♪ Yeah! ♪
[Normal voice] Now...
I don't know. I don't know about this.
What do you think? What year was it?
-That's exactly how it happened. -Yeah.
-This was, like, 1992, 1993.
-This is so believable that I think it's not believable.
-I think he's lying.
-What do you guys think? -What do you think?
[ Audience shouts, "Lie" ]
-They think lie. Wait. But -- Alright.
Ben Stiller, we're all gonna say it's a lie.
[ Drum roll ]
-It's a lie? -Is it?
-It's true!
-[ Cheers and applause ] -He's the best!
That's why he's the greatest! That's why he's the greatest!
That is why Ben Stiller is the greatest, right there.
-I told you he's a legend. -"True Confessions," everybody.
My thanks to Laverne Cox and Ben Stiller.
"True Confessions."
We're talking to Ben more after the break.
Stick around. All truth from now on.